[Music]
do
my
[Music]
so hi this is don jacobs i
was i just want to welcome you all to
the table um i want to just thank you
all for being here
and i just want to just um i'm so
thrilled that you're able to
to meet with us in this way but i also
want to name something
um sometimes i have this ability just
have this natural energy
when i'm talking to people that i
don't want to come off insincere about
some things
this has been a very interesting and
very challenging week
um specifically with some of our members
here um
just alone at with our members here at
the table there have been people that
have been
um in the hospital and
not knowing what's going to happen with
their loved ones
um we've have i know of people who have
been forced out of their home and
i've known people that for them
financially
things have turned for them completely
upside down
that their future is just unstable
and then on top of that we had
our country um leaders that
are at at our national level
um who it has been
just a whirlwind um
and that's just putting it very mildly
um i i personally have been on social
media
i have watched some of the comments and
it's not that that
i'm shocked at what the country's doing
i'm more
personally hurts i would say
by how sometimes we talk to each other
um and it it's been one of the things
that for
it's been it's it's a challenge and so
when i get on here and i say welcome to
the table
i don't want to leave out the fact that
some of us are coming because we're
excited to be here
but some of us are coming here because
this is this need this is a space where
we need to be able to land
safely it's the only safe space that we
have
um and i hope that this is a space for
you that you feel like you can
land where you are seen where you are
heard
where you are
just loved quite frankly
so as i do welcome you here and i'm glad
that you are here
uh with that being said i do have one
announcement about meetups
um meetups are um are something that we
do
especially since we're still doing a lot
of things virtually uh we're able to
have a face-to-face connection um
sometimes for depending on the meetup we
i
still do a virtual connection but it is
a space for you to
for us to kind of connect with you
one-on-one so that's something that
you're interested in
uh you will begin there's a link that
will be in um
in the notes and they also can visit our
website
um at the table tx.com and you'll be
able to find out information more
information about meetups
um so i am going to transition us
into a prayer before we start worship
lord thank you so much um for
just this ability to come together um
laura it's been it has been a wild week
for some of us it has been um
just it's hard to even put into words
exactly
where some of us have been and i pray
lord that you just open up our hearts
open up our minds
allow us to know and to feel
and connect with you in a powerful way
help us to learn to love each other in a
way that brings you honor and glory
in christ i pray amen
thanks don that was well said
so
come to the water
all who are thirsty
come drink
come to the table
[Music]
those who are weary
those who are needy
come receive
[Music]
come to the river
taste and see
come to the water
all who are thirsty
come and do
come to the table
all who are hungry
those who are weary
those who are needy
come receive
hey come to the river
come to the river
taste and see
oh my
soul fears for you
oh
my soul
[Music]
oh
my soul
[Music]
i will taste and see
that you are
[Music]
i will taste
and see
[Music]
we will taste
and see that you are good
you're good to me
[Music]
oh
you oh
my soul
come to the water
all who are thirsty
come and drink
[Music]
come to the table
all who are hungry
come and feast
[Music]
in light of some of the stuff that's
gone on this week um
i felt like this might be a fitting
passage just for us to reflect on
as we go into this next song
it's out of romans 14 and 15 these are
just some of the verses that stuck out
to me
in those chapters therefore let us stop
passing judgment
on one another instead make up your mind
not to put any stumbling block or
obstacle in your brother's way
let us therefore make every effort to do
what leads to peace
and to mutual edification
he who is strong ought to bear with the
failings of he who is weak
and not just to please himself each of
us
should please his neighbor for his good
to build him up
may the god who gives endurance and
encouragement
give you a spirit of unity among
yourselves
as you follow jesus so that with one
heart
and mouth you will glorify the god and
the father
of our lord jesus christ
accept one another then just as christ
accepted you
i wanted to play all the poor and
powerless and
one of the things that a friend of mine
actually glinda who shared last week if
you guys were with us
uh was saying earlier this week is
sometimes
um you know we quiet ourselves and
remind ourselves to kind of
take a seat to our own voice and all the
things that we're feeling and passion to
say
to give space and room for someone else
to speak and listen to them and
especially when those people are
speaking with clarity
and truth and love um so i just wanted
to
as a community um give some space for us
to take a seat ourselves um
and give some space and some room for
the voice of god for the voice of truth
in our lives the voice that says there's
room and space for
each person and each story um
because in all things
we um at the end of all things
there's not just a god for for one
people or for one belief or for one
tradition
but he is the god and the lover of all
all people all things
um so let's just take a second and
reflect on that
and um sing this song together
[Music]
all the poor and powerless
and all the thieves will come confess
[Music]
and know that you are holy
and we will cry
[Music]
end
all the hearts who are content
and all who feel
and all who hurt with nothing left
will know that you are holy
[Music]
and we will cry
shall we
go on and scream it from the mountain
[Music]
oh
will sing out hallelujah
we will cry out
[Music]
hallelujah
we will sing
[Music]
we will see
screaming from the mountains
[Music]
that he is
thank you that you are the god and
creator of all things and all people and
god i just pray that you would give us
hearts
to hear and to listen to one another to
see
each other
god help us not to be blind
to your fingerprints and other people
even when we are different
even when it's hard
to see anything beyond our box would you
help us to have eyes to see
the way that you do would you help us to
have ears to hear
the way that you do and would we be
people who are
building each other up who are looking
out for our neighbor
who are trying to bring goodness and
light
and reconciliation
in a time where there's so much division
and so much yelling
and so much anger god
may we be the feet and the hands
and the heart of jesus in this earth
we love you god and pray that you'd keep
doing your work in our lives
keep changing us and transforming us
even when it's hard and we resist it
lord would you keep doing your work
help us to lean into it in jesus name
amen amen
thank you thank you mindy that was
really really lovely
and um good evening everyone grace and
peace
it is great to be with you um
we are let's see we're kicking off a new
series
this evening it's titled uh epiphany
a radical invitation and
the idea of the the season of epiphany
in the church calendar
is basically that it's a time to reflect
on
who christ was and is um who he reveals
god to be
and what our response to that revealing
is so in a sense
um you know if you think about like the
word epiphany this is sort of what an
epiphany is
it's when something shines forth and
um grips us so you can see that
in many ways epiphany is the perfect
follow-up to the christmas season of
advent
because advent that's very much um what
theologians might
they call like the marian posture um you
know like mary mother of jesus advent is
all about um waiting and receiving
something from god that we do not work
for or earn
it's really a season of contemplation
quiet and grace
epiphany following christmas that's
different
this is about our response as the church
to the gift
of jesus so with that in mind the title
of my message this evening is tribes
and tribalism tribes and tribalism
and believe it or not i actually wrote
this message about two weeks ago
um right where leading up to the new
year and so i didn't yet you know know
all that would happen um however i think
you'll see
um i've tweaked a few things but um
overall i think the the spirit was
guiding me because it feels really
really timely i didn't have to change
much
and um now having said that if you were
kind of hoping that i would
um hit the the issues of this week a bit
more straightforwardly
um well then you probably haven't read
my e-letter i was pretty straightforward
in that
and so if you didn't get that just let
me know um i can
you know send it your way um but
this text or or this message tonight is
going to be centered
um in a little bit different way though
i will you know touch on on
our cultural things happening so uh our
text is gonna be our scripture matthew
chapter two
verses one through twelve and
um let's go ahead and we can um read
that together so
uh we'll begin verse one after jesus was
born in bethlehem in judea
during the time of king herod magi from
the east
came to jerusalem and asked where is the
one who has been born king of the jews
we saw his star when it rose and have
come
to worship him when king herod heard
this
he was disturbed and all
jerusalem with him when he had called
together all the people's chief priests
and teachers of the law
he asked them where the messiah was to
be born
in bethlehem in judea they replied for
this is what the prophet
has written and i quote but you
bethlehem in the land of judah are by no
means least among the rulers of judah
for out of you will come a ruler who
will shepherd my
people then herod called the magi
secretly
and found out from them the exact time
the star had appeared
he sent them to bethlehem and said go
search carefully for the child as soon
as you find him
report to me so that i too may go and
worship him
after they had heard the king they went
on their way
and the star they had seen when it rose
went ahead of them
until it stopped over the place where
the child was
and when they saw the star they were
overjoyed
on coming to the house they saw the
child with his mother
mary and they bowed down and
worshiped him then they opened their
treasures
and presented him with gifts of gold
frankincense and myrrh
and having been warned in a dream not to
go back to herod
they returned to their country by
another
route so
so a huge huge problem um
you know for human beings really not
only now um
but really throughout history but you
could argue particularly in our world
today
a huge problem is tribalism i suspect
uh this is driven in no small part by
the um the information
and misinformation silos
we now inhabit in our world particularly
very
via social media but regardless you know
it's just it's a tribalism is a huge
huge
issue and there's really no end in sight
to it
um now to be clear tribes
uh are not bad you know tribes the way
we kind of form ourselves into groups
and tribes that tribes can be community
and relationship um tribes can be a
shared sense of identity
a feeling of being known a a
source of of common values
and thus a common way of life
but like everything tribes can be
dangerous
and i believe they're dangerous for at
least three reasons um
first a echo chambers
tribes so quickly become echo chambers
of settled opinion
where we all just know that we are right
because well look around uh
everyone in this tribe agrees and we're
all geniuses here or at least we feel
like geniuses because
we've implicitly agreed never to
disagree
so um like this is this is basically
what an echo chamber is right echo
chamber is a place
where someone um only encounters
information and opinions that reflect
and reinforce
what they already believe right no
challenge
no pushback no growth
b the second reason tribes can be
dangerous is because of
arrogance right they can so easily
devolve into this
culture a culture of arrogance a sense
that um
our tribe is the best tribe
uh but not even just the best tribe but
um perhaps even more dangerous the only
good tribe our motives are pure
our eyes are open we alone are the
possessors and
arbiters of goodness and truth
third exclusivism tribes can be
dangerous because they become
exclusive clubs for our kind of people
outsiders are not welcome now this
brings up the question um like what do
you mean by tribes right like what types
of tribes are there and of course
um when i use this term tribes i mean
they they come in a variety of forms
um they they tend to form along the
lines of let me let me list a few things
here
um race uh gender
nationality uh politics
families and clans um class
levels right like about money um
geography so just where
people live um and then of course
religion
i mean basically you can form a tribe
around like nearly
anything which in light of the dangers
mentioned above
might lead you to think well
let's just do away with these tribes
these things are dangerous
but as i mentioned earlier human beings
are deeply inno
and inescapably social right we derive
our sense of identity
from the tribes we inhabit in fact
child psychologists will tell you that
it's important for kids to grow up
in a tribe of sorts you have to you have
the family tribe and that family needs a
strong culture
strong values a strong sense of of look
kids this is who we are
this is how we act and here in this
tribe you are
loved and here in this tribe you belong
that's great uh same on the religious
end
sometimes uh with kids we can get this
kind of progressivey idea
where we don't want to force religion on
our children this can be particularly
tempting if you've come from maybe a
really
really kind of not just conservative but
almost a fundamentalist
kind of control hyper-controlling
situation and so you kind of swing the
pendulum you're like i'm not doing that
to my kids
so we might be be very tempted to to try
this thing of um
of not giving our kids any religious
input
because we don't want them to get tribal
so we're just going to let them decide
for themselves
uh what whatever they come to but again
psychologists child psychologists will
tell you that while it can
there's you can kind of see the logic
there but that's something that the cure
just might kill the patient
because it turns out kids actually do
better when they have an intentional
religious tribe to grow into
because it helps them orient themselves
in the world
this is who we are this is what we
believe this is who god is this is what
is right and what is wrong this is how
we understand the world
uh and i mean heck if you don't give
your kids a try they'll probably just
end up finding some more dysfunctional
one to join anyway so so all this leaves
us
in a real pickle because on the one hand
it seems we can't do without tribes and
yet on the other hand
tribes can be so man what's the language
so
so dangerous so so in-groupy and
out-groupy and just just the worst
i remember a few years ago at the the
last church i
was at someone met with me and they very
bluntly they sat me down they said your
church has a problem
and i said no it doesn't no joking i
said oh no i'm
i'm sure it has a lot of them uh but go
ahead you tell me the one you have in
mind
and they said it's the clicks
this church has clicks like this group
of people are friends and that group of
people are friends and
the groups you know they can be sort of
you know cliquish
and i said uh huh yeah i mean i could
i could see what you're saying and i
agree we could
always be better about keeping groups
open to outsiders but i know the people
you're talking about this person they
had names some very specific names of
people in the church who were acting
like
and i said i mean i know they're pretty
dang good like honestly they're not
they're not really the the kind of
insecure
closed-off kind of people and so we just
started to go back and forth like kind
of not argue anything but we were just
processing and it was difficult like
because there was this need on the one
hand
for there to be friend groups in the
church
but then how do you keep them open
enough
that they don't start to feel cliquish
and it was a hard awkward conversation
and ultimately it ended when this person
just said i
i just think it's cliquish and we
kind of parted ways and i thought long
and hard about that conversation
and and honestly it's just difficult
because on the one hand we can't do
without tribes
and on the other hand having a tribe
centered on certain values
uh inevitably creates this this kind of
in-group out-group dynamic which i mean
on the mild end can be cliquish
and on the extreme end can be downright
dangerous i think you see this tension
around tribes play out even in the
biblical text
itself i mean if you think about it when
god wanted to reveal himself
god chose a man abraham in genesis 12.
and then he said abraham i'm going to
make you into a great nation
a tribe a people who eventually became
known as the jewish people in fact they
were literally
known as the twelve what of israel
the twelve tribes of israel
twelve tribes who combined to form
one mega nation tribe
uh that's the old testament and then and
of course there's other examples but
then to kind of jump over the new
testament uh one of the very first
things jesus did
once he began his three years of
ministry was to call
12 people the number by the way is
interesting right got the 12 thing how
it kind of parallels the story of israel
and these 12 people would go on to found
a community a
tribe centered on jesus known as
the church and what was and is this
tribe
constantly tempted to do
we are tempted by the exact problems we
talked about earlier
echo chambers arrogance and exclusivism
every tribe is tempted by these things
and
when we succumb to them we
we have now slipped into tribalism
tribes at their worst
which is why it seems not insignificant
that for all of the tribalism in the
bible and no doubt you can find it
the spirit of god in god's wisdom keeps
humbling and opening up the tribe
and sometimes it's very obvious as as
when for example jesus tells the
pharisees
he gives them this lecture he says you
are i'm kind of paraphrasing but
basically you are so caught
up in your your religious kind of ethnic
cultural pride
you can't even see how far from god you
are in fact
the prostitutes and the sinners they're
going
to enter the kingdom of god ahead of you
he's like not mincing words
in other words what's he naming he's
saying the very people that your little
tribe within a tribe has
excluded as the outsiders they are going
to become
god's god's insiders so that's a i mean
it's a pretty blatant one it's like a
slap in the face of their tribal pride
uh but at other times it's it's more
subtle
more subtle and i believe this passage
we read matthew chapter 2 verses 1
through 12
illuminates that did you catch who
it was that made the long journey to
worship
the christ child notice
it was not the reigning king in
jerusalem herod that we find out later
he wanted to
kill the child so clearly it's not herod
in fact it wasn't even like the high
priests or the religious leaders
at that time uh who
was it who discerned the birth of the
single most significant baby ever to
grace the earth
the magi the magic what is a
magi that's not a word we use a lot
here's the definition magi sorcerer
or magician sorcerer
or magician i love that god does things
like this i just love that wizards harry
potter met jesus
and by the way they were almost
certainly not kings that's part of much
later tradition
comes a few hundred years later that
seems to be kind of more mythical
like these the magi kind of transformed
into kings uh i love how
christian writer nadia votes wherever
she put it when she said we three kings
of orient are
not in the bible so so who are these
magi who were they really like well they
were
they were these kind of um i mean it's
hard to put
kind of pigeonhole them because there
are probably a lot of things these kind
of astrologers right they're watchers of
the stars so kind of astrologers
uh scientists but um
probably with some religious bents to
them so maybe like kind of priest
wizards
sorcerers from the east i mean
for sure we can say they were certainly
foreigners uh
pagans and yet it was
they who discerned the times
it was they who had the eyes
to see it was they who were sensitive to
the spirit
and who came and gave gifts and
worshipped the christ what am i getting
at
here's what i'm getting at it seems that
god's
circle of welcome is
always bigger than ours every time
god's circle of welcome is always bigger
than ours
we keep trying to shut the tribal doors
and god keeps kicking them back open we
keep thinking
that we are the know-it-alls who have
nothing to learn
while god keeps dropping hints that
sometimes
it's the outsiders who get it first
and and this of course is no one-off
story i mean if you've ever read the
bible then you know
that that for all of its pretty strong
tribal tendencies
for all of its talk of of election
and the people of god uh if you follow
the trajectory in the story what do you
see
you see that the circle of welcome keeps
getting
bigger and bigger and bigger
all right so what does this mean for
us like in our lives let me put it like
this um
here's step one in your life step one
find a tribe
gain an identity uh
it's important right you need it like
your kids need it you'll need it your
whole life we all need to belong
we all have to orient ourselves in the
world as i said earlier
um and i'm by the way not just talking
about joining a church though i think
arguably that is
as one of if not the most important
tribes you'll connect with
um but but i'm really just trying to
name
about i'm trying to name all the tribes
right this is true of all areas of your
life like you need to find
good healthy vibrant tribes
um but here's step two step two you then
have to
prevent your tribe from turning into
the worst version of itself so you you
kind of spend a few years
getting into the tribe and then you
realize your purpose shifts
now i've got to prevent this drive from
becoming
um just the worst and what's the worst
version arrogance echo chambers
and exclusivism arrogance
echo chambers and exclusivism in other
words to be faithful to the spirit of
christ
there will come a time when you will
have to be the voice in the wilderness
that demands your tribe eat a slice of
humble pie and shut up
and listen and learn
and acknowledge that our stuff stinks
too there will come a time when you will
have to be the one demanding a seat at
the table of your tribe
for whoever just might be considered the
stranger
the outsider the non-believer the sinner
the pesky question
asker tribes don't like pesky question
askers
but there's going to come a day where
you will have to be the one demanding to
see the table for them
why because that just might be how the
holy spirit chooses to
show up in your midst
and it's the only way
your tribe isn't going to decay into a
stultifying petrifying arrogant
echo chamber the worst
kind of tribalism
and i'll close with this make no mistake
about it
what we saw a few days ago in dc that
was the result the manifestation of
of this kind of tribalism an echo
chamber gone off the deep end
and of course um the political left has
also had its own
violence and off the deep end moments
over the summer so this isn't about just
you know picking on a group um
but the thing is that this that sort of
thing that this kind of tribalism gone
crazy this is
um it's not just sad i've heard a lot of
people naming it so sad and that's true
it is sad
it's not just sad uh it's dangerous
it's dangerous
so where's the hope um i
think i believe christ shows us
a better way let me say that again
christ
shows us a better way you see
christianity
it's a strange tribe friends um
we're supposed to it's supposed to be a
strange tribe let me put it like that
we're supposed to be a peculiar people
uh a tribe it's like a tribe that is no
tribe
um a tribe whose doors are to remain
open to the other a tribe that
at its core is called to remain
humble listening
servant-hearted like the christ we claim
to follow
and so i'm calling us let's be those
kind of people and in your tribes the
various all the ones you inhabit
um keep the doors open
to the wizards in your midst
say the wizards it's a metaphor i mean
the outsiders
the strangers the ones no one else wants
around the unexpected visitors
because sometimes god gives you gifts of
insight and
wisdom that you could receive no other
way
don't let your tribe devolve into
arrogant
know-it-alls into self-righteous
political social religious
pharisees who have nothing to learn
and again uh this week
this week it was the it was a certain
group you know next week it's
it's a different group um
but but the key is uh we've got to stay
humble we've got to stay learners
and honestly let's do the same thing in
our church i mean for goodness sake
it's in our name the table
let's keep expanding the circle of god's
welcome
to everyone liberals and conservatives
gay and straight black white brown
because jesus has come not to coddle
insiders but to welcome
outsiders which means that's our job too
that's our job church let's live it
let me pray for you lord jesus
i ask for wisdom
wisdom and awareness over every person
who can hear my voice
that all the tribes we inhabit it's so
easy to just get
pulled into the echo chamber pulled into
our perspective it's so hard to break
out of that
so god i just pray for wisdom
and an awareness just a sensitivity to
your holy spirit
that something in us would would just
awaken
when our tribes are taking
a dark and dangerous turn
so lead us guide us
help us to love like you love
help us to expand to join you
in expanding that circle of welcome it's
the powerful the life-changing name of
jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
come all proud come all
come
[Music]
come on
come from the shadows
come out of the dark
there's room at the table
we
[Music]
every race every
nation come all rebels
come all gay from the fringes
come to jesus to a table
full of grace to the table
come and stay come to the
table
come eat and drink
[Music]
recline at the table
come let down your guard
you're never a stranger
just come as you are
[Music]
come accepted
come
[Music]
come except
we're ready to feast
the party's waiting
there's more still to feed
the harvest is ready
go fill every seed
go live out the mission
as a kingdom of priests
as the kingdom of priests
[Music]
come behold
accepted
come now come
[Music]
accepted
come now come
oh my gosh miner family that was
beautiful thank you so much for that
thank you all so much for uh coming uh
this evening
um and if you are in need of any kind of
support or prayer just send us a message
um you can make a comment below
um someone from our leadership will be
make a point to reach out to you
you can also give financially to the
table there will be also a link
in the notes below where you can do that
and to dismiss us just a short
benediction
to me the god who created a world of
difference
in vibrancy um go with us as we embrace
each other in all his fullness and may
the son who teaches
us to care for the stranger and the
foreigners
go with us as we try to be good
neighbors
in our communities may the spirit who
breaks down
all of our barriers and celebrates our
communi our
community go with us as we try to find
the courage to create
space of welcome for all
thank you and have a great week
you